un avion de combat ukrainien survole des
terres agricoles au nord de la région de
Donetsk le front a été repoussé 50 km
plus loin mais l'été dernier il n'était
qu'à 10 km de ses champs qui ont été
régulièrement bombardés
1 2 3 ils sont tous jonchés domicile et
de roquettes qui se sont écrasés on ne
sait même pas de quel type de munition
il s'agit regardez j'ai trouvé ce
morceau de Schrapnel sans même me rendre
dans le champ celui-là a explosé mais
des morceaux qui n'ont pas explosé
peuvent être n'importe où ils viennent
des bombes à sous-munitions
par là-bas sur la droite on a trouvé un
conteneur de bombe à dispersion plein de
mines antipersonnelles
dans la ferme au travail Victor ou
banette s'il n'y a pas eu de Moisson
l'automne dernier
la seule activité de l'entreprise ces
jours-ci c'est d'aider les autres
fermiers à nettoyer le peu de récolte
qu'ils ont réussi à rentrer une activité
qui devrait bientôt toucher à sa fin
l'agriculture s'effondre les revenus
s'effondrent les gens sont de plus en
plus pauvres il y a zéro développement
pourtant ici la propriété et ses
équipements sont intacts les fermiers
vont perdre une année mais les
exploitations pourraient survivre
dans la région de rerson ravagée par
l'occupation russe les perspectives sont
plus sombres
vous allez voir beaucoup de ruines le
long de la route il n'y a pas une maison
indemne dans ce village et certaines
sont complètement détruites
volody mirzaïet nous conduit à ses
champs
on dirait que les gars ont trouvé
quelque chose
bon on va regarder le tracteur a fait le
tour donc en termes de sécurité on est
bon Serge comment tu l'as remarqué
alors qu'initialement il ne voulait que
marquer la position volodime change
d'avis vu qu'il manque le détonateur on
va simplement le ramasser en faisant
attention
l'engin pèse 40 kg
fais gaffe
le chant a été inspecté mais pas
complètement nettoyé pour le dire mais
des rubans blancs là où il y a des
munitions non explosées qui ne peuvent
pas être transportés
les tracteurs les contours
si nous ne labourons pas les terres là
où nous pensons qu'il y a moins d'objets
dangereux
sera une année blanche
la mer s'inquiète volody mir est un ami
elle n'aime pas le savoir dans les
champs très dans un explosif
écoutez c'est une
paire
sorte
seulement aujourd'hui et je ne suis pas
contente il loue des terres qu'il
cultive vous comprenez et les
propriétaires demandent quand allez-vous
nous payer
c'est comme si on vivait dans des mondes
différents
bon j'y vais
tire-toi ça me touche les gens qui vont
dans les champs non déminés meurent dans
des explosions c'est grave il y a même
des pubs sur Internet maintenant pour
des entreprises privées de déminage
qui le ferait pour de l'argent mais il
n'y a pas d'argent les gens ont perdu
leur matériel leurs graines les récoltes
qu'ils avaient stockées
tout ce qu'ils auraient pu vendre pour
rentrer un peu d'argent tout a été
détruit
dans ce seul petit district il y a eu
trois accidents impliquant des ouvriers
agricoles et des Mines rien que le mois
passé dont deux mortels les deux
chauffeurs de tracteurs qu'on voit sur
cette photo ont survécu mais sont
sérieusement blessés
la chair de mon bras était arrachée
jusqu'à l'os ici aussi
et pour la jambe l'os est cassé donc il
ne peut soutenir aucun foie
c'était douloureux mais je les
supportais et l'opération s'est bien
passée ils disent que je vais me
rétablir
Nicolas veut retourner travailler
je suis le seul enfant de ma mère notre
maison a été détruite donc je devrais
continuer à prendre des risques si je
veux économiser et reconstruire la
maison ou bien en acheter une autre
Nicolas laffirme son patron lui a promis
que son travail l'attendait quand il
sortirait mais pas avec le même tracteur
son patron le voici York un homme qui
prépare les semis du printemps il
demande aussi de l'aide pour
reconstruire sa grange
c'est ici qu'on gardait notre récolte
tout a été détruit après que nos soldats
ont libéré la zone
à peu près 40% de ces terres seront
cultivables au printemps il espère
pouvoir faire mieux et continue donc
d'inspecter lui-même ses champs avec les
moyens du bord ici des éclats d'obus il
veut nous montrer quelque chose qu'il a
trouvé plutôt ce sont des mines
antichard elles sont armées vous roulez
là-dessus et c'est fini et regardez
comment elles sont alignées jusqu'à
l'autre bout du champ
dans un autre champ ignore brûle les
cultures non récoltées il dit qu'en plus
de fertiliser les sols cela aidera à
déceler plus facilement les objets les
engins les munitions russes qui
ralentissent le secteur agricole
ukrainien le poumon économique du pays
entente paix comme en temps de guerre